do you like walking around your own
properties yeah do you do that sometimes
well with with my with my slight
handicap that I have it's not as easy I
do have to ride on my scooter right but
before I became sick with with this
neuropathy that I have my wife and I
used to come in every night walk through
the bread money are you do you pick out
are you are you very we have children we
go home we have dinner with them almost
every night Sheldon do you ever do ever
step back and say I'm the CEO of a US
company that generates more and more of
their money in Asia I've reflected on it
is it on you does it did you think that
that's how Las Vegas Sands was going to
turn out that way no but most of your
wealth is coming from Asia now yeah well
women I've built up a lot of wealth
while I'm here from my previous business
isn't from my business today and
thankfully according to Bloomberg you're
the 10th richest man in the world
10th maybe it's but think about that
there's 7 billion people
that means this 6 billion 999 million
nine hundred and ninety thousand people
that are not at my god it's a lot I'm
not sure about the numbers right you're
pretty close but do you ever think about
that
I'm just curious look at me what do I
think about the fact that most of my
money is made in Asia sure well that and
also the Pete what I hope it comes up to
99 percent it's it's over 90 percent
today yeah sure what's wrong with it
no there's nothing wrong with as long as
I do what the government wants me to do
I love it I don't think I'm ever gonna
retire what have you learned as you've
gotten older I've learned to seek advice
from other people and get more than my
own viewpoint on some
I've learned that that now that I've
accumulated incredible amounts of money
I could do some good for Humanity I
don't necessarily want to build a
dynasty because a friend of mine says
that he only cares about the faces he
can see so when you think ahead reducing
in three generations from now my
children's children children do I really
care about them I don't even know who
they are they don't exist
what is the difference Sheldon how did
life change for you from being a 38
billion dollar man from being a 1
billion dollar man what was a difference
not much well one we can philanthropic
Lee do a lot more and we can expand the
scope of our philanthropy and
particularly a medical research so
instead of putting on out of million
medical research a year we could put out
700 million yeah so then what do you
want your legacy to be you're 81 right
80 80 actually I'm 60 because 80 is the
new 60
I want my legacy be to that I helped out
humankind what do you think your mark is
here in Las Vegas what do you want
people to think of when they think of
Las Vegas in you I don't think that me
in Las Vegas I mean I've changed the
face of Las Vegas by focusing on
convention based marketing mom's
business mom when nobody else was doing
that nobody else
everybody everybody decried it they
belittle didn't said oh they don't
gamble when the convention has come and
they don't gamble to a certain extent
that's true but we compensate for it by
the the price of the rooms and everybody
started following you and everybody's
following me Steve Wynn is more of an
entrepreneur than the other guys the
other guys meaning uh meaning
Ceaser's and MGM and Boyd they're not
entrepreneurial how are you able to be
so outspoken when you ask me a question
I try to be honest I flunked diplomacy
101
I don't know I'm outspoken because I am
I could never make a I couldn't be a
liar I can only tell the truth I would
be very bad lair I say that my father
told me my father never left me with
anything material but he left me the
richest as rich as I could be with
values and he always told me never lie
about anything you got to be honest
because if you lie about one thing the
second time somebody is going to ask you
you're going to make up a lie to cover
that first line and then pretty soon
you've got a whole chain of lies and
then you were completely exposed but
it's not the line that I'm talking about
it's you know I talked to so many CEOs
and you know many of them are not able
to be as out are not as outspoken as you
worried about finality their work now
they're worried about their word about
their stock price are they worried about
saying the wrong thing they're worried
about their investors they're worried
about pitch do about all the things that
you just mentioned write about that's
division she's not mine